Oh
now I don't think the two are quite the
same thing in a religion you have to
have you have to believe in some
otherworldly or metaphysical force I
don't think that that's the case with
the democracy at all the more democratic
governments ought to be neutral as far
as those big questions about the meaning
of life what happens after death and so
on are concerned I do think there has to
be a common agreement to abide by
certain rules and laws and without that
things of course would collapse very
quickly
I think that the particular nature of
the separation of church and state in
the US as is true of Protestant
countries in yerba or majority of
Protestant countries in Europe does have
a lot to do with that then that the
authority of the Vatican of the Catholic
Church was much more opposed to
democratic development in the past then
the Protestant church is where the
Protestant churches have a tradition of
being suspicious of authority certainly
of absolute authority encouraging a
certain kind of individualism since
every individual according to the
Protestant faith has his own pipeline to
God and doesn't need to go on his knees
or her knees priests
yes I do think that that the it's very
clear what it is to be an American
citizen it's it's a political concept
more than anything else it means that
you are loyal to the Constitution and
and you're a good citizen and then you
can have whatever culture you wish in
your private life so you have the
hyphenated citizen it's much harder for
Europeans to accept that this is
possible also the fact that so many
Americans still themselves are religious
makes them much more accepting of other
people who are equally religious even
though and of religions that you know
are not Christian or and not all that
familiar
yes I think that's probably fair to say
also the US has a long history of a kind
of folk Christianity in the form of
evangelism evangelical faiths which in
itself is very close to her to business
and entrepreneurship people who start
mega churches or or promote that tiller
their their religious faith on
television our business men as well as
preachers and that goes back to you know
the boom is the beginning of the United
States it's that's why i started my book
with the story of Elmer Gantry